Hey everybody its charlie we got huge news about some alternate spider-man costumes
Very comic book moments that they deleted out of infinity war early on in the process
Including alternate costumes for other characters some of which seemed like they were saving for
Avengers 4 because we have seen with some of the Avengers new costumes are gonna look like during Avengers 4 so we got to break
It down there's a new round of that game giveaway
It's either a Red Dead Redemption or spider-man
Ps4 or either one you guys want all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave a spider-man related comment on the video, uh name a new winner at the end of this
So we're gonna start with spider-man's black costume because that's probably the biggest news then. I'll break down the other
Alternate Avengers for costumes so you can see early on that
They planned on doing a version of the iron spider suit that was way more
Authentic to the comics then this black version you can see is exactly the same only black
Colored is not supposed to be the symbiote
But because they were fighting for their lives on an alien planet
You can see why early on they would consider putting him in a black costume to reference Secret Wars like heaven foggy
Definitely didn't want to do venom
But this is the closest we could get to symbiote without actually doing the symbiote all of the iron spider scenes that Tom Holland film
For infinity war were full motion
Capture versions of the suit the benefit being that the visual effects artists can make the suit look like whatever they want without Tom Holland
Having to come back in and shoot new scenes if they want to change the costume late in the process
But they just open up their uber version of Photoshop that they use turn all the colors way down and bang you have your black
Costumes spider-man but based on the early versions of these scenes the Avengers who went to Titan to fight
Thanos would have also been fighting the outriders in spider-man would have worn three
Different costumes during the movie the original stark tech suit that he starts out and the iron spider suit that he gets when they're climbing
Into orbit then let just refer to this version as the black mode iron spider
Probably just a plan feature for this version of the suit like deploying extra armor
When all the outriders were gonna go crazy on them what ended up happening as we all saw in the theaters that they got rid
Of the outriders on Titan because they already had way too many characters there
The fight was already really complicated and super expensive and because they planned these movies so far out
They probably won to save a few of spider-man's big
costume changes for future potential spider-man movies like far from home
You can kind of see the wheels turning in their heads behind the scenes as they're envisioning all this there's already too much too soon
Let's save that black suit for the next movie
So we still have a few
Surprises left up our sleeve the new Steve Ditko looking black suit that we've been seeing on the set of spider-man far from home also
Looks an awful lot like this version of the iron spider suit
This movie's a prequel because you know in the at the end of infinity war you turn into like
a
Lot of times if they have a really amazing idea early on that hits the cutting room floor
They'll try to reuse that in a later movie. Like this is really awesome. But we've already got way too much stuff going on
We'll just include it in this future movie. It's the same deal with Joss Whedon in the gray Hulk
He originally wanted to do grey Hulk in this big battle with Ironman here
But decided that they were already trying to cram too much stuff into the movie
So just told Kevin Feige here, you can use grey Hulk in a future movie if you ever want
It's just a really interesting twist for his character
This infinity war black suit obviously wound up becoming the Nick Fury shield stealth combat suit
We've all been seeing behind the scenes pictures up almost like spider-man's noir costume
but with thick armor plating and combat boots
So you can see how if they wanted to do this and it was supposed to be this big twist like oh wow
Look at this cool new black costume
Spider-man is wearing it would have completely undercut that if they had already done it during infinity war
We've been talking about New Avengers for costumes and yes, spider-man is gonna be in Avengers 4
But I'm not expecting any dramatic costume changes for him
There have been rumors about multiverse time-traveling different versions of existing characters, but most of the spider-man moments
I'm expecting are in paying off Tony's grief because you have to address that like Aunt May needs to find out that Peter died
Then when he does eventually come back Peter reflecting on the totality of what he's been through and looking forward to his
restful quote-unquote summer vacation with his friends q far from home giant Mysterio attack
We also got a look at the version of Thor's costumes. They almost went with during infinity war
It looks suspiciously like his new costume that he gets during Avengers 4
But just like them holding up on spider-man's black suit it seemed like what happened here
is that early on they knew that they were splitting the story up for both Avengers movies they decided that because Thanos was going to
beat the crap out of them during infinity war and they needed to rally during Avengers 4 the easiest way to
Show them growing and becoming more badass visually is to just give them new costumes
So they just held off on giving everyone really shiny new costumes. So thanks to some of the toy releases
we've seen what some of those new costumes are supposed to look like whether or not they're featured heavily in the movie or if it's
Just for a couple of quick scenes
A lot of times really cool toy stuff doesn't necessarily translate to a lot of scenes in a movie
You also notice that they almost decided to give him a gun is his main weapon instead of doing the new hammer
Stormbreaker and you can just hear all the fanboys in the background screaming
Blasphemy Thor has used guns before but because this is such a big deal
He's mostly associated with melee weapons like axes hammers
The only part of his costume that I was disappointed with a little bit was than them giving him his new eye
Right away instead of letting him be pirate for for a little while longer
Just wish they'd left that for Avengers 4 so he could still be pirate angel Thor but from what we've seen Iron Man's
Nanotech armor always looked like this like there weren't that many big changes from start to finish
the only other characters with
Radically different costumes early on were Captain America with a more military colored armor during all the Secret Avengers scenes during the movie
I agree completely with their final decision to just have him wear the ripped torn version of his Civil War armor showing the scales underneath
Much better a comic book Easter egg in a much better visual
Representation for his character arc. He's been worn down by all the tragedy all the crap. This happens in Civil War
Just like the suit has been worn down we've been talking about how do you show characters?
I've grown give them costume upgrades cue shiny comic books scale armor and Avengers 4 and get that man his new shield
All right Will's up at 8 minutes we just got a load Tony don't Hulkbuster armor
prototype for caps new shield and the making the make the
I get so many questions about Thor's magic belt them making your it doubles his strength in the comics
So it's totally possible. They could pay that off during Avengers 4 it would make sense
If you're giving all the characters costume upgrades and he really wants to go toe-to-toe with a nose
Let me know in the comments
Do you agree with their decision to hold off on black costumes spider-man and save that for a future movie?
There is a whole bunch of other Marvel and DC stuff that's been dropping recently
So leave your requests for spider-man and Marvel videos in the comments below
Congratulations, Joe B Romo. You're the giveaway winner from my last big Marvel video. Please email me on the about page of my channel
So I can get your contact details
click here to learn about the new Winter Soldier series that they just announced and click here to watch Tom Holland explained the trilogy of
Spider-man movies that they're planning at Marvel. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay. Awesome. I'll see you guys tonight